cobra kai wouldn't be a continuation of
the karate kid films if each character
didn't have their own complicated
rivalry so of course daniel's teenage
daughter and excellent karate student
sam has her very own nemesis
tori tori's only been slinging kicks in
the dojo since season two but she's
already made quite an impact on the
story even instigating the best fight
scene of the series
is that the only way you're not a fight
dirty
this isn't a tournament
there are no rules but when she's not in
her karate uniform tori
may seem strikingly familiar she's
played by peyton list who's been
modeling and acting for most of her life
at only 22 years old she already has 56
acting credits on imdb
on casting list and cobra kai series
co-creator john hurwitz told indie wire
we wanted somebody who was a rival that
can be intimidating to see him in a
physical way and when we saw peyton's
audition she just was totally badass and
very intimidating in a way that she
would be a legitimate threat to samantha
larusso
however the ferocious tory who loves the
cobra kai dojo's no mercy creed is a far
cry from list's adorable early roles and
her bubbly laugh track roots on disney
channel
after a couple of early uncredited roles
including a brief moment in spider-man 2
peyton list made her true acting debut
in the 2008 romantic comedy 27 dresses
as the younger version of the
protagonist jane nichols
catherine heigl of grey's anatomy stars
as the present day jane who is an
eternal bridesmaid having been in 27
wedding parties
liz plays the eight-year-old version of
her in the beginning of the movie who
discovers her knack for solving wedding
problems
thank you so much sweetie you saved the
day
from 2011 to 2018 liz starred as emma
ross for all four seasons of the disney
channel series jesse and three seasons
of its spin-off show bumped
emma is the eldest of the kids that the
titular jessie comes to new york city to
nanny
and the resident teenager before her
siblings grow up while this wasn't
list's first acting part it is her
longest running role
you are the girl of my dreams i know
coincidentally one season 4 episode of
jesse references the karate kid with the
title karate catastrophe
however despite her cobra kai role now
this character emma isn't the one
practicing karate it's her younger
siblings
in the episode they referenced the
famous wax on wax offline from the
original movie
list has had parts in a variety of tv
movies shorts and one-off episodes but
she's also been in a few more well-known
films
while she was still a regular on jessie
she took a role in the diary of a wimpy
kid films she plays the main character
greg's crush holly hills in both
roderick rules and dog days
the second and third films of the series
at 13 years old list was already playing
the popular blonde in school holly as
the pretty new girl in town catches
greg's attention when she gracefully
skates past him at a roller rink
she's sweet and friendly though
reasonably unnerved in the face of
creepy comments from greg's friends
the pair later bond over their shared
torment from having older siblings
after her character unbunked left summer
camp to become a model list took on a
totally different kind of teen show
hulu's supernatural thriller light is a
feather
indiewire compared the series to pretty
little liars as it also features a group
of teenage girls faced with the death of
one of their own who are then forced to
unravel the mystery
that said it's a touch more disturbing
than you might expect with some body
horror and
unnerving insects list plays the teenage
cliques leader olivia in the first
season and then returns briefly in the
second
hey guys hey did you see my new ride
yeah it's amazing the premise of the
series centers on the slumber party game
light is a feather stiff as a board in
which the players attempt to levitate a
participant
or at least trick them into feeling
levitated like bloody mary it's a
perfect game for a horror adaptation
as it often involves telling the person
in the center how they died light as a
feather kicks off with the teen girls
playing the game in a cemetery before
they're faced with a horror of one of
them dying just as described in the game
the series received mixed reviews with
some critics wishing for a little more
humor but valerie anne of auto straddle
wrote that quote
the characters felt fleshed out instead
of the caricatures of stereotypes horror
films can sometimes deliver
this role served as a leaping off point
for liszt as she then went on to play
the complicated tory in cobra kai
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you